[Musique]
kevin robert en a 44 ans et habite au
wac ou à la plaine des cafres et moi
l'actrice depuis 2004 et puis président
de la commission des agricultrices au
sein de la fdsea depuis à peu près deux
ans c'était un parcours très très
difficile parce que moi ce que ma
rencontre et principalement sur mon
exploitation
c'est surtout des problèmes fonciers et
le coup de main comme on l'a eue c'est
de parler bien sûr c'est un syndicat des
cols qui défend ben ali zari cultuelle
lectrice est donc mal a été élu à ce
moment-là président de la commission
agricultrices et qu'on me dit toujours
nous les jamais par hasard un endroit
mon expérience va apporter aux autres
d'un petit peu il peut rencontrer ses
dix fils mêmes difficultés ne pas
accompagner zodiac tout à fait comme ça
fait comme si en tant que femmes nous
nos produits mes animaux l'an dernier
toulon année il me disait sur
l'exploitation avec du maraîchage sur
l'exploitation d'un ami cars 2 le fumier
de mes animaux me dis pas que mais c'est
là des cultures biologiques mais michel
a dû résonner
il pourrait être qualifié à moi de
personnes courageuses et des cv rendant
ce qui me fait seaman avait plein de
courage pour arriver au sommet dès
aujourd'hui malgré l'avis est
persévérante
parce que dans la vie si vidic viard est
peut-être de ma vitrine tout autre vidéo
parce que pays-bas peut-être bien que
s'il m'avait continue et peut-être bien
que sinon massimi point cap et que mon
ami pense que ce que me défends légitime
mais ça va je comprends
sauvegardez justement l'été pour que
nous puissions travailler et surtout
mettre à disposition par les terres que
les gens ici pour sauver ce que nous
amène dans les assiettes réunionnaise
c'est à dire il faut que les politiques
et méconnaît que le département il
travaille beaucoup là-dessus c'est
promouvoir le produit local
s'il nous arrive à faire ça et bien là
dès que tu réunionnaise je pense que
[Musique]